this is episode sons of Mars uh both a
both a really funny goofy one you know
sort of like the earlier season but also
it one or two little tells here in there
that I really likes they're connecting
to what's going on this world and more
the apocalypse and stuff like that okay
so we got the return of Magic Man which
is just great to see him again
you know he should be really annoying
but I'm surprised I actually kind of
like that character like I'm thinking
like oh no this is a full episode two
hands is gonna be like another you know
yeah LSP or something like that that was
like better this is that you're pretty
funny um and I think a lot of this just
how energetic he is with everything I
mean he seems like he's a troublemaker
needs a jerk but he's so upbeat about
all the time um so so he's there and the
brother from Mars or brothers as a
couple faces comes down once and take it
back to Mars cuz he's done a lot of
really bad crimes he disguises himself
as Jake and Jake is him thanks they only
take the wrong person Fingal's at Rome
and the president of Mars which is the
Abraham Lincoln Memorial
um horse of course naturally I mean that
didn't see that coming um goes and tries
to sentence Jake to death and he doesn't
kind of accidentally and realizes he
made a mistake so he goes and offers up
his immortality and fin trans go back to
get Magic Man but did he escaped imagine
where they knock him out oh it is not
talked about okay attendee let go of
Magic Man saw was a man yeah Minnie
mantacorn who didn't thank him but then
reveal that he sho thanked him because
his new prison is shame and then finesse
what they say Jake said his new prison
is shame um yeah I mean the the first
major things I noticed with this one
probably the the earth having a giant
hole in the side I love that well
tsunkat yeah actually if you go back to
five short graybles ah he's in the room
the the emo Philips yeah he's in the
room and there is a globe that is
consistently spinning and other shows oh
well there's the giant chunk missing
from it that is the earth I say okay and
he also in space there's a whole bunch
of garbage too which I found interesting
I didn't know what that meant
yeah like I think a hotdog or the earth
is like destroyed and blown out that's
retarded ring around the earth oh you
know yeah that's a good pie I saw
everything like stuff that came from
Earth yeah but that yeah that's what I'm
saying they're like it kind of creates
that ring or that big chunk floating in
space but also the fact that there is
like we see Mars has like its own you
know there's there's people on Mars I
mean it's like I know there's even sort
of thought that like Land of Ooo is like
they're hinting that's like life after
the apocalypse and stuff that's still
called oh and you're not exactly sure
how its formed and everything and it's
so still kind of like is this earth this
is the past present future right and
here you clearly see if I guess you say
you saw it on the globe yeah like I said
I mean I do you see this episode it's
like okay that's obviously what that
glove was because initially you see the
globe and it's kind like oh that's cool
could that be the planet maybe maybe not
but this like literally solidifies it
because now you're like oh that's the
chunk that's taken out of it and yeah I
like to learning a little bit more about
like magic man and the history of Mars
and stuff um but it was also really
goofy ahead of very just out of nowhere
and Bing I mean that thing with the
whole mini mantacorn talk you remind me
of that gingerbread cookie they had like
a big it's a little cui at the end so uh
no I thought was fun and I like the I it
was one of those actually I was almost
camp it's one of the few episodes let's
count hoping to get even more out of it
I almost wish it was like a longer
episode because I was kind of like
muffled oh no even more I mean I wanted
more about like the Land of the Dead the
Lincoln travel to and like how he turned
into the Statue and what does that mean
a lot of this one I'm like what does
that mean will that come back we'll to
be continued I don't know so yeah
they liked it it was just as goofy as
sir the earlier seasons too so a world
building yeah little piece of world
building there and you kind of hit the
mark on a lot of things when you two
were talking about what is this world in
the apocalypse or not Louis it's hard
for me to say because of course this is
this is my first exposure to the more
weird or episode which I'm assuming it
gets even weirder in some places because
yeah this seemed to have a very solid
structure behind it well this aesthetics
are like a more common episode do you
know I have a structure to them it's
just a lot of times bizarre things
happen during that structure like
there's very few episodes where you're
going like that there's always like two
straight up but everyone's around
swerves a little bit but it always kind
of comes back you know there's spastic
shows where there's no real structure at
all Adventure Time has always had a
structure but bizarre things happen in
that structure like instead of a
denouement you got a Manticore doing a
lot of small so look we instead II
wonder if Manticore will ever appear
again
I wanna see him get out of his prison of
shame why do you want to see two before
I forget that the joke at the end the
final lie you know I remember to approve
the new shame and you know takes listen
Finn says what do you say and you're
expecting Jake to get it wrong and he
said some psycho he says says he lives
in a prison of shame and they cut there
I just thought that's a total unexpected
non joke which everybody like weird
about it so the whole time you saw Magic
Man was looking at a picture of him and
someone he loved
yeah marbles was that and it's like he
does regret something and more match man
isn't a prison of shame there you go
maybe he only decided to help Finn when
he when he saw the picture I mean yeah
sudden tone sure did I even had change
of them Indian to music reading he's
kind of like changed expression and it
says it's downstairs yeah that was
something I really liked because you
know it's like Oh blah blah blah blah
blah and then he throws a picture and
it's like kinda looks and he looks back
up then he looks again he's like it's
downstairs
like thing yeah as if the person whoever
that woman was like she would have
helped
and it's like any just like I'm an
asshole or even he remembers like what
it's like to want to help somebody or
someone's in danger or something like
that oh oh hinting and I kind of do like
that ya know the whole show is one giant
hit I mean that's our what's fun about
it you know the episode doesn't start
off with this has been this is Jake this
is the Land of Ooo it's just like it
just drops you in the middle of this and
the whole show is kind of working
backwards as to what these people's
history is what the history of the world
is where everything came from and it's
it's a lot of fun it's you know these
people's personalities but then we find
out their history and how they got those
personalities and how this world came to
be
slowly but surely it's it's it's really
cool there's a lot of empty there's
maybe a stupid question but Jake can
shape-shift right so he could so how
come he couldn't resume his normal shape
again on Mars I think that's probably
I'm guessing that's the magic thing as
magic what's he charged it the
Switchback it's sort of Magic Man not a
stance then yes a line but I love the
overhead projector game yeah we have no
video footage of his crimes but but glob
here can do good Robert well old kids
don't even know what they're how many
schools still use overhead reports
probably probably have you at school
ever had an overhead projector used yeah
well those transparencies the one we
draw on it's the same right I did
another of those no no and I love the
desired the brother to I thought that
was a renewable one that's one thing
that I was gonna bring up did you catch
what the brothers name is I did not Jory
anyone God the guys blob oh my Grod
that's all for the heads all for the
faces the forfeit if that thing was God
come on okay okay throughout throughout
the whole show you know how like when
something go wrong with a guy oh math or
something like that yeah instead of you
know it's two halves where where it's
devil my god they'll say Oh My glob and
sometimes they'll change to oh my Grod
oh my
yeah and it's like oh okay whatever and
it turns out you just think they're
making it up or something I guess this
was glob and Rob and stuff like that
making me wonder though it's like a
deity you recognize yeah but it's I'm
very curious now oh yeah if something
ever showed that though yeah at this
point in time it's kind of like is that
a bastardization of God is it something
else but now that you actually see there
is a physical being that represents all
of them yeah but that has making me
wonder because clearly that that that
being with like the Drano head did not
have it didn't look like any of the
other Martians that were in the crown
hmm yeah which I wanted to bring come
back to because right before we started
you were gonna bring it up yes oh okay
cuz during it he goes to the dead world
talks with death we've met before
yeah and to get back Jake soul he said
what will you give me he holds up a
little penny and he's like no it's gonna
take more than that this time it said
I'll offer up my immortality and then
like you hear a bunch of noises and the
last noises bang OH
like yeah like an assassination yeah and
then there's a memorial yes like it's he
gives us the reference no no I not
busted history reference I took it more
as instead of him being in existence for
all this time he died in his normal time
yeah that's why he's he got rid of his
immortality so he died when he was
supposed to instead of living on and and
now there is a memorial there I'm not
actually yeah based on continuum is
circling the drain yeah so you know what
this means
okay cosplayers in Washington DC I want
you to address miss Finn and Jake I need
you to go to the Lincoln Memorial and
you're gonna email us or tweet us a
picture of you in front of Lincoln tell
us if you still maybe it hasn't we just
there's nobody emailed us yeah
have you done it email it or tweet it no
actually that is that like that's that
that's like something like that those
ideas are really like even most a lot of
adults would be able to comprehend a lot
of that honestly give I don't know if
I'm digging too deep into no no no such
thing as reading too deep into something
I disagree with that when someone writes
down the bunny is running sometimes it
just means the bunny is running what
does that big just means that Abraham
Lincoln will it wasn't immortal who
would then sacrifice his immortality to
death in order to revive a
shape-shifting dog
well I like to think wasn't the
president Mars he is the king of - nope
it's it kinda sounds like a fat cause
suddenly there's a memorial there of him
and again I mean it's now no that's
strangely enough the closest thing that
makes sense to me so did I think you can
totally legit yeah yeah I'll stick by it
is it a referenced again no not yet at
this point in time so like I said I may
be just reading too much into it but I
like you thing though like my thing
awesome women I'm sorry sweetheart
oh sorry take my things he is my
favorite character to Pilate Abraham
Lincoln you must believe in yourself was
that in the pilot yes he was like except
I think it was on the note I haven't
watched did you ever watch the pilot oh
my oh no no that's right I haven't seen
like the bottle with the candy-zombie
theme or some bill I know
you believe in yourself though I've had
people on Facebook trying to show me the
pilot - I was just yeah whatever always
leak inside and out curious the pilots
different than what the show is ah and
to me if you're gonna watch a pilot it
should fit into the continuity or you
know something or just take it as just
something so yeah like just a separate
entity and we'll yeah don't reach out to
the pilot sometimes it's fun to watch a
pilot if only because it's interesting
to see what initial ideas were but yeah
I think it as a separate entity yeah
look at cuz Ben it's not even his name
isn't even thin yes pen oh really
named after Pendleton yet so I mean even
that changes that's what I'm saying it's
not necessary to watch that pilot
because there are a lot of changes watch
it as its own entity and not part of
this but is it as good as the wand the
short that you showed us um no it's not
the longest ten times better okay you
are missing a phenomenal master really
short yeah like wow there for reading
too much into things the title sons of
Mars yeah what is that referring to
specific magic man in the I was going to
say really
are they sons of Mars they very
different sorts of beings and you know
is Abraham Lincoln a son of Mars as well
I know son of Mars I just thought it
meant you know people of Mars pretty
much yeah my interacting what would sons
of Earth sons of Mars and not just trial
of Magic Man because that would give
everything away well yeah I'd watch it
yell of them are like magic man was
actually Jory called her right away
she's like when magic moans all wrapped
up and everything I love how you co said
over Final Fantasy because he looks like
a black man yeah which like oh my god he
looks like Magic Man and I'm like
awesome this is magic wait it's not the
guy who like did the twirl of magic
one of the things that should be voiced
by Neil Patrick Harris you are
yeah he's Prince bubblegum or uh he's
symbols that don't you miss sounds like
you should be voiced by Neil Patrick
Harris no no Tom Kenny I know but I
Harris and Abraham Lincoln was voiced by
Pendleton ward where Leo can I love I
love Lincoln's voice just always yeah I
cuz that's how they get would talk no no
no that's my impression for school so
yeah final thoughts America shame share
he gone